the average Americans right now are
saying that wait this is now really
pinching me layoffs have now touched
somebody I know layoffs have touched my
nephew my cousin you know what this
economy is not helping me and all the
spin that the White House was putting on
it was keeping people aligned but now
you even have Democrats and independents
saying to Biden hey wait a minute man
this isn't spin this isn't transitory
and so things are shifting and so people
are being impacted by layoffs uh food
prices especially have not retreated SO
gas price at the pump you know bounce
around a lot eggs don't do that they get
there and they kind of stay there and
like the price of food products kinds of
you know ends up staying there so the
average American right now pbd is
hurting and now they're voicing it and
it's coming out in surveys that the
administration and others cannot put the
public spin on and say oh well it's just
transitory it's not that bad the average
person is saying wait a minute